6 25 on your friday morning a shout out
to everyone in the clark county school
district and educators everywhere
wrapping up another week of the new
school year
and now if you please some well-deserved
spotlight time for the ccsd police
department's social media
officers get the serious work done but
the facebook keeps it chill with posts
like
don't be like this booze-lipped bunny
drive sober especially around our
schools patting the nevada state police
highway patrol on the back for getting a
more than four times the legal limit
impaired driver off the road and
pulling over a 44 mile an hour in a 15
mile an hour zone hot dog driver
highlighting a passenger acting like a
brat
thinking it's okay for someone with a
revoked license to drive as long as the
passenger her was 21 and had a license
it is a facebook page worth following
and you don't want to miss all the
really clever hashtags that they have on
there because it is a pretty funny we
always want to know what's cool at
school so if you've got something let us
know cool it's cool under the community
tab at eight newsnow dot com or just
email cool at school at 8newsnow.com